вже 28 років поспіль Україна вперше
неділі жовтня відзначає День працівника
освіти сфера освіти - це фундамент
формування та розвитку особистості А
освітяни - це ті хто створюють умови для
побудови основи цього фундаменту сфери
що в свою чергу впливає на розвиток
економіки країни та світу кожен На
світінен на собі відчуває всі мінливі
зміни світу разом ми вистояли від
вторгнення та захоплення східних
регіонів у 2014 році тоді змогли швидко
створити гідні умови для відновлення
навчання українських виборчих освіти з
Криму та Донбасу
та світова епідемія коронавірусу не
стала на заводі сфері освіти в Україні
тоді ми стали сучасними бо в нашій
роботі з'явилося більше цифрових
технологій сьогодні ж чергове
випробування
російські окупанти по всій території
України майже щодень руйнують заклади
освіти але і це не стає на заваді на
шляху до світлого Та мирного майбутнього
адже разом Ми все відновимо На жаль
маємо втрати і серед педагогічний
працівників і серед вихователів і серед
учнів
але цей біль і пам'ять про тих хто
загинув не дає нам жодного сумніву для
того щоб зупинитися наперекі Русі
викликав я тішуся що освітяни впевнено
крокують широким хоч часто тернистим
шляхом разом працюємо незважаючи на
негаразди трансформуємося та мотивуємо
інших навіть в умовах жорсткої війни в
Україні Кожен вихователь і вихователька
вчителів вчителька позашкільники майстри
про втихів викладачі гідно тримають
освітній грунт шляхом організації
освітнього процесу підтримки батьків та
дітей власного професійного розвитку ці
кроки є невід'ємною частиною розвитку та
зростання
саме у ваших руках
булимяніють вогники знань умінь та
навичок які формують наше майбутнє
українські освітяни - це не просто
талановиті прогресивні особистості
сьогодні ви Захисники України волонтери
психологи як і власним прикладом
формують сильне майбутнє бажаю вам
шановні освітяни і ти тільки вперед адже
ви провідники незламності і непохідності
нашої держави
на вас з довірою і Надією дивляться
мільйони дитячих очей
силам безмежного терпіння життєві
мудрості натхнення та оптимізму ви наших
героїв вам пишається вся країна і весь
світ зі святом Будьте щасливі та здорові
Разом до перемоги тримаймося ми сильні
ми Україна З повагою до вас
[музика]